die Astrid-Lindgren-Grundschule in
Mettmann NRW man ist hier durchaus
Flüchtlings zugewandt zwei Unterkünfte
gibt es bereits in der Nähe als die
Grundschule Wahllokal war zur letzten
Kreistagswahl holten die Grünen die
meisten Stimmen jetzt aber sollen auch
noch in die Turnhalle Flüchtlinge
einziehen zwischen Schule und Kita viele
Eltern möchten das nicht
es ist schon schwer genug das 50 Leute
auf so engem Raum leben da braucht man
auch nicht in Summe noch
400 Kinder die auf dem gleichen Gelände
dann auch noch sind meine größte Sorge
ist einfach für die Kinder weitere
Einschränkungen da gibt's ja
Kinderturnen und diese Angebote wird
halt dann nicht mehr geben gerade jetzt
im Winter so wie hier sieht es derzeit
vielfach Ausland auf Land ab diese
Wirklichkeit anzunehmen empfahl nun der
Vizekanzler seiner Partei es gebe eine
gewisse Dramatik man müsste pragmatisch
die konkreten Probleme lösen auch wenn
es bedeutet moralisch schwierige
Entscheidungen zu treffen es klang wie
ein aufwecken eine Aufforderung sich von
einem zentralen grünen Glaubenssatz zu
verabschieden dem unbedingten Jahr
zuzuwanderung wie kriegen jetzt
plötzlich Menschen geschenkt erklärte
etwa katrin Göring-Eckardt nach dem
Herbst 2015 komm weniger euphorisch
klang noch im jüngsten Wahlkampf sie
ja wir haben Platz für diejenigen die
unseren Schutz gemeinsam brauchen
nun aber bläst der raue Wind der
Realpolitik den Grünen auch bei diesem
Thema frontal ins Gesicht doch viele an
der Basis sind zu einer Kehrtwende nicht
bereit selbst wenn sie sich erstaunlich
pragmatisch plötzlich sogar als
treibende Kraft bei Abschiebungen
gerührt wir erwarten dass es hier von
Nancy face und von Joachim stand endlich
Fortschritte gibt was das Thema
Rückführungsabkommen angeht schnellere
Abschiebungen sind in der aktuellen
Situation sicherlich nicht grüne
Priorität wir brauchen endlich wieder
eine faktenorientierte Lösung für die
Kommunen mehr finanzielle Unterstützung
und abschiebeabkommen oder dergleichen
werden auf Dauer definitiv nicht
funktionieren ob eine Begrenzung von
Zuzug notwendig sei diese prinzipielle
Frage beantworten viele grüne weiter mit
Nein jüngst gab es das sogar schriftlich
die Ampel reformierte das
Aufenthaltsgesetz aus dem Zweck
Steuerung und Begrenzung wurde
Begrenzung gestrichen vor allem auf
Drängen der Grünen wie es hieß
Begrenzung sei ohnehin nicht durch
heizbar solche Debatten brauchen wir
überhaupt nicht führen und das tun wir
als Partei auch eben aus dem Grunde
nicht sondern wir überlegen wie können
wir den Kommunen helfen wir können wir
den Bundesländern helfen nachhaltig auch
vorbereiten möglicherweise auf andere
Migrationsbewegungen so sehen es viele
grüne was womöglich erklärt warum sie
diese Woche sogar ein Scheitern der
asylreform auf EU-Ebene riskierte im
Juni hatte sie Verschärfungen dort noch
verteidigt bekam dafür von der grünen
Basis wie Kritik manche sahen schon ihre
Chancen auf eine neue Kanzlerkandidatur
schwinden diese Woche nun drängte sie
energisch darauf den eu-plan zu
entschärfen nach grünem Gusto bis heute
stand eine Einigung aus und auch die
müsste danach noch durchs EU Parlament
wir wollen verhindern dass wir
Massenlager an den Außengrenzen haben
und wir werden uns im Europäischen
Parlament sehr sehr stark dafür
einsetzen dass sich diese Perspektive
auch durchsetzt denn nur wenn weiterhin
auch menschenrechtliche Schutzstandards
gelten können wir dem am Schluss auch
zustimmen gibt es keine Lösung vor der
europawahlkommenden mai wäre das für
viele in der flüchtlingsversorgung einen
fatales Signal hier in Hessen an der
Bergstraße etwa sei die Kapazitätsgrenze
vielerorts überschritten Hilferufe gibt
es seit langem auch von grünen es sorgt
am Schluss dafür dass wir eigentlich uns
um alle gleich schlecht oder gar nicht
kümmern und das fordert natürlich dann
am Schluss auch dazu heraus dass man die
Diskussion führen muss wie gelingt noch
Integration und da müssen wir sagen das
gelingt momentan nicht und wir fördern
damit natürlich auch
Parallelgesellschaften die wir alle
nicht wollen auf diese Wirklichkeit
deren Anerkennung habe ich nun anmarnt
weil sie er nun seit mehr als einem Jahr
hin und fragt sich wie er und sagt warum
die Parteien in Berlin sich mit sich
selbst Beschäftigten anstatt ihren
Auftrag wahrzunehmen gute Politik zu
machen für die Menschen in diesem Land
und zugeschaltet aus dem bayerischen
Wahlkampf ist uns der Parteichef der
Grünen guten Tag Herr nuripur und
erlauben sie gleich die erste Frage
Robert Habeck meint die Grünen die
Wirklichkeit anzunehmen und moralisch
schwierige Entscheidungen zu treffen
Frage an die Parteichef was heißt denn
das konkret
das bedeutet dass wir sehen dass die
Realität sich ändert und wir sehen dass
beispielsweise in vielen Kommunen die
Belastungsgrenze erreicht ist da fehlt
nicht nur ein Geld dafür jetzt an
Personal da fehlt ein Wohnraum und
dementsprechend braucht es da Abhilfe
und das arbeiten wenn miteinander und
Abhilfe heißt was konkret
das heißt erstens dass man mehr Geld für
die Kommunen braucht zweitens dass die
Leute die ankommen auch Arbeiten sollen
und nicht mit arbeitsverboten belegt
werden sollen das bedeutet die dritten
dass wir die Verfahren schneller und
straffer machen müssen das kann nicht
sein dass von 560 Ausländerbehörden
diesem Land über 100 nicht mehr
digitalisiert sind das macht einfach
alles nur langsamer das bedeutet dass
wir Rückführung und migrationsabkommen
brauchen und eine europäische Lösung
letzteres ist ja sehr oft immer wieder
genannt worden
wir sind jetzt aktuell Strecke dahin zu
kommen aber das Wort Begrenzung habe ich
gerade Steuerung sagen wenn wir
Steuerung sagen dann wird es natürlich
ja zu Begrenzung führen das ist eine
Binsenweisheit wer keine Begrenzung will
keine Steuerung will der sagt dass sie
Grenzen geöffnet werden sollen das ist
ja nicht die Realität aber wir wollen
die Realität wie sie jetzt ist gestalten
damit Humanität Unordnung beides gibt es
zur Zeit einen Außengrenzen nicht
ausreichend auch im klargleich
Miteinander stehen warum haben sie dann
bei der Reform des Aufenthalt sgesetzes
das Wort Begrenzung gestrichen
das hat die Koalition miteinander
vereinbart ich war bei den Verhandlungen
nicht dabei aber am Ende ist es bei der
Steuerung genau das weil wir steuern
heißt das dass wir schauen wer kommt
rein und bekommt nicht rein auch der
Kanzler sagt ja jetzt die Zahl der
Flüchtlinge sei zu hoch wird es mit der
grünen Spitze eine Begrenzung geben und
wenn ja wie ja ja noch mal wir müssen
Steuern aber nein wir dürfen nicht so
tun als gäbe es einfache Lösungen es
gibt Gründe warum die CSU in Bayern im
Wahlkampf beispielsweise nicht mehr von
der Obergrenze spricht weil sie ja sehen
dass das nicht so wirklich wirksam ist
und weil es auch niemand mehr glaubt
dementsprechend sind miteinander den
Kommunen helfen in Europa Lösungen
finden damit Humanität und Ordnung
kommen damit die Steuerung auch
funktioniert das ist das Gebot der
Stunde und daran arbeiten wir alle
zusammen in der Bundesregierung so hat
der Kanzler diese Woche im Kabinett auch
mit Blick auf für die grüne
Außenministerin richtungsweisende Worte
gefunden zur krisenverordnung der
europäischen Asyl Reform hat er da ihre
volle Unterstützung
der Bundeskanzler und die
Außenministerin ziehen an einem Strang
es darf keine krisenverordnung geben die
auf Kosten Deutschlands entsteht es darf
keine Verordnung geben dass die die
besagt dass ein landkrise rufen und dann
wird niemanden registriert alle werden
durchgelassen und kommen nach
Deutschland das ist nicht das Gebote
Stunde das ist nicht das was wir wollen
und da sehen wir uns einig und deshalb
haben alle zusammen auch gedrückt damit
das Verhandlungen gibt und die
krisenverordnung in der ursprünglichen
Form ist auch nicht mehr da die ist
verändert worden und das ist gut wir
haben es eben den Beitrag gehört dass
vor Ort gesagt wird auch von grünen
Beiräten bei den aktuellen Zahlen von
Zuwanderung sei Integration gar nicht
mehr möglich was muss für Sie denn
daraus folgen
das muss daraus folgen dass wir den
Kommunen beistehen und dass wir vor
allem die Leute so schnell wie möglich
in Arbeit bringen ich sehe das selber
wenn ich unterwegs bin es gibt
Pflegeeinrichtungen in der vielen
Pflegekräfte zwei Häuser weiter zehn
Meter Luftlinie entfernt ist eine
ausgebildete Krankenschwester die mit
dem Arbeitsverbot versehen ist das ist
ein Test und der wichtigste
Integrationsmotor immer schon in diesem
Land war der Arbeitsmarkt das so schnell
wie möglich zu bewerkstelligen dass die
Leute arbeiten und auch Arbeiten sollen
das ist das was es jetzt braucht das
heißt die sofortige Erlaubnis wie sie
jetzt von der Fraktionsvorsitzende der
Grünen gefordert wurde die teilen sie
auch
es wird laufend von der Wirtschaft
gefordert vieler Unternehmen kommen zu
uns sozusagen bei dem aktuellen Mangel
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt an Fach- und
Arbeitskräften brauchen wir die Leute
die gerade auch hier länger angekommen
sind und das kann doch nicht sein dass
die jeweils in den Unterkünften sitzen
und Däumchen drehen und deshalb braucht
es einfach einen schnellen Anschluss in
den Arbeitsmarkt
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
danke Ihnen